now remember this is a hundred percent
live so this is unplanned you never know
what you're gonna find on our lives fie
my name is Brittany Smith and for the
first time in about six months
I'm reunited with the wildebeest so very
exciting to be back on Drive with full D
and of course we have some very very
special Safari live fans that well that
are in a final control so a big hello to
them and I'm sure a lot of you know who
they are hashtags fire live if you can
guess which Safari Live fans are sitting
in final control right now remember if
you can send that questions as well once
you've finished guessing on the hashtag
a safari live as well just pop it on any
of the feeds that you might be watching
on so I'm trying to get towards husana
the young male leopard who we left at
the end of dr quack post here this
morning but the city is a little bit
close to the road for me to go shooting
past him I'm just trying to see if it is
the same big must ball we saw this
morning
- which Safari live viewers are sitting
in final control they might be on Safari
a cheetah cheetah and there might have
my little brother is their safari guide
even the elephant's listening you
started keeping still I'm gonna try
maneuver us into a slightly better
position
without getting too close to him
he's obviously chosen the most difficult
spot for us to get around looks like you
might be having a snoozer against that
tree looks like he's been here all day
and it's not is it the must warm like he
was look at that he's resting his face
on that branch what is he doing actually
I can't really see what he's doing he's
being oh yeah so it looks like he's
actually am so guys this is quite a
possibly dangerous situation so I'm just
gonna move the car into a place that I
can escape if I need to be
it looks like he's quite badly injured
from it looks like the size of that
injury it looks like he tangled with
another big elephant and it looks like a
test punch as something's pulled out a
lot of his insides so this is quite a
serious injury and that's why he was
probably trying to rest his head up on
that on that tree okay so ashamed boy
now we can't really see what's going on
on the other side and that looks very
very serious from the side he's not
showing any little displaying any
aggression at all towards us at the
moment but you can see him leaning
against that tree to try to take the
weight off the his injured left side
shame big guy now male elephants when
they do fight can it can be very very
serious looks like he's probably been
injured by a big tusks and it's pulled
through now animals of course are
incredibly resilient and they can
sometimes come back from what we
consider to be absolutely horrific
injuries
when I need to do now is I need to get
hold of the sabi sands quickly just
because an injured male elephant like
this can be potential threats to people
on safari and if he gets close to safari
lodges so we just need to inform someone
and I'm gonna do that quickly while we
do that let's go across to Taylor so she
can say good afternoon good afternoon
everybody and welcome to the sunset
Safari again my name is Taylor mccurdy
and on camera with me I'm very lucky as
David I just wanted to make it awkward
for him right now as most of you know
you can chat to us and ask us all sorts
of questions all you have to do is
hashtag safari lad and you can talk to
us via the YouTube chat - very sad about
that elephant Mike Green said it can be
quite dangerous especially if we are
around during bush walks that is an
animal you do not want to bump into now
are we ready we're heading to the
Birmingham voice have you had this
morning well that brained got this
morning and then we revisited a little
bit later on on the drive so that's
where we're going now I suspect they're
going to be flats up we'll have a little
look at them and then maybe go and look
for something else and come back a bit
later so for all of you diehard safari
life fans out there you know you can
come and visit us right we come to the
savvy side and you come and stay around
you come and see us and well we've got
Matt and Lisa sitting in final control
today having a little watch and I just
wanted to make a public announcement
thank you very much for the chocolates
and the apple juice coffee
very yes with us we wish you could stay
longer so actually I have a question
then for Matt Aneesa sitting in final
control do you have any questions Wes
how cool is that instead of having to
type away you can just ask a question
oh there's actually David hold on tap
but have they already drank there's a
whole herd of elephants they've just
gone past the dam can you may have seen
them I didn't see them I didn't know
they were there but we'll try and catch
up to them I think there's a sneaky road
down yeah an old tree trick that I used
when I we had hooker Moody
excuse me Impala coming through hello a
part of making all sorts of strange
noises and oh no you know what they're
gonna do they're gonna be so sneaky I
know exactly where they're gonna come
are they're gonna go feed in this
thicket we shall reposition quickly
sorry everybody we'll try and get a view
of elephants but they're going down
basically pass the law does not last for
each other and as we drive along though
speaking of elephant bulls and masks and
brains head office in interesting this
morning Megan you've asked and how
exactly do elephants come into mass well
they just start producing a lot of
testosterone at certain times of the
year and at a certain age is that again
there's a lot of factors that will
determine when an elephant bull comes
into must but essentially were one is
that there's an overload of testosterone
being produced being reap what
reproduced being produced in their
bodies and it basically causes them to
go but wild they become very excited and
all they want to do is chase after the
females they basically have drinkers on
and they don't even acknowledge anyone
else around them unless you drive behind
elephant bull and mass and and sort of
bother them then they're gonna turn
around and go well I told you I didn't
want you to drive right behind me I
think before we get to these lions we're
gonna try and anticipate we hold on
everybody
that's a bumpy section on the road we're
gonna but and then hopefully we'll get
to see them because there were quite a
few of them some of you may have been
watching on there on the Dan cam in fact
there's a massive animal pathway that
runs on line with the the rooms of Rhea
tiller and come all the way it comes all
the way up here the thing is is that I
don't like to offer it for elephants
because I think it's dangerous because
if something goes wrong you can't really
get out very quickly at least if we've
got the rose and things
so y'all that's the plan and we just
wait for them and here's a particularly
thick area so I think they seem to be a
few bulls and massed around on the
property that could have been bothering
these breeding herds so we don't want to
bother them anymore but actually what we
might do is I might just pull off here
and you'll stop and listen quickly
maybe we can hear them that's what I'm
going to do like these elephants are
tiptoeing through the bush hmm now I
can't hear any cracking of branches just
yet
are they still down at the dam did they
maybe turn around and go towards
Retailer dam itself anyways I'm gonna
sound like anybody's been able to spot
them
they've gone sort of further north okay
we'll just wait patiently there's only a
couple of animal pathways that I think
that they would use they will get them
eventually Tristan is going to be on
Bush walk for a little bit so off you go
and join him we are indeed we are going
to be on Bush walk and that is why we
are a little bit tardy this afternoon so
as Taylor mentioned my name is Tristan
on camera I've got a Craig aka the
Batman and we're hopefully going to have
a wonderful afternoon it's a warm very
very hot day and so it should be good
conditions for walk we should have a few
insects around hopefully moving about
maybe even some butterflies I've already
seen a couple of monarchs floating about
so maybe see if we can concentrate on
some butterflies and anything else that
comes our way we're gonna try and see if
we can go and the reason why we like I
say are on foot is because Antigua has a
problem we it overheats a little bit and
so the sound then goes and so we waiting
for [ __ ] to cool down so we'll jump
into [ __ ] a little bit later and it
gets a little cooler but for now we're
gonna be on foot I did have some audio
for some elephants not too far away
very close sounds like actually just at
the dam itself so maybe what we gonna do
is try and head down that section and
see if we can find those in ease and
having a look at them on foot and then
otherwise anything else we can see now
while we try and get everything sorted
out and try and get ourselves down to
that area let's send you back across to
brains and see where he is and what his
plans are so far now that he's left that
elephant hey guys I'm just warning
everyone this this is not the nicest
view around so if you are sensitive you
might not want to look so I've reported
I'm just waiting for a call back
from the wardens and stuff and you can
see they're quite obviously that it's a
task wound from another elephant so it
is it isn't from human beings but and
you can see the wound is quite serious
and you can just see that from his
behavior now you can see there's even a
stick stuck in there so I mean this
looks relatively recently within the
last couple of days and shame you must
be in so much pain so it'll be up to the
sabi sands to decide what to do
I've just got a way chat to till I hear
back from them and if they need GPS
coordinates and things like that
those look quite bad shame and he's
showing no sign of aggression or
anything like that he's just resting up
against this weeping waffle tree so he
keeps throwing sand on the wound and
what he's doing there is trying to keep
the flies off it
now of course that injury is quite bad
but he doesn't look too weak just yet so
the Predators I possibly could take
advantage of this and that's what Matt's
wondering will will Lions take advantage
of this elephant there is a strong
possibility depending on how weak he is
hyenas as well would definitely I've
seen hyenas harass injured eddie's
before for up to two days before
actually managing to kill the elephant
so it is one of those difficult things
but that is nature and that's how nature
plays out day after day when we're not
watching so one must remember that we
are observers here we're not here to
interfere
Ramat it's such a difficult question
you're asking what about if the animal
is endangered will they interfere you
saw what happened with that wild dog and
they didn't interfere so if the injury
is deemed to be caused by human beings
by some way then the vets will sometimes
interfere and try heal it but most of
the time in these situations nothing
will happen
that if they do decide to interfere with
this elephant it's it's it's difficult
to say what will happen but they just
need to know about it because it is a
potential safety risk
- all of us are chaired I mean bush
walks and at the game drive vehicles and
if he wanders close to camps and he's
injured and trying to get water or food
so that's why I've notified people he is
a potential safety risk I wonder if it
was that masked of all we saw this
morning that that is something a big
muscle like that might do to a younger
ball like this while in must not
necessarily when they're out of mast but
when in must that is something that
massive mass ball we had on the Sunrise
Safari might do
now Rhonda's asking about the age of
this Eddie he's old he's not he's not a
very old bull I'd say he's probably
around 30 so here's an adult and Shana
is throwing dirt on that wound again and
it's quite bad you can actually see
there's a little looks like an acacia
stick that's got actually stuck in some
of the tattered flesh there so as I said
it's quite fresh and at the moment he
might not be a problem but if infection
sets and he could become a very
dangerous animal here so whether the
choice is made to leave them or
euthanize or treat I'm glad I'm not the
one who has to make those decisions
and we've had quite a close look at the
injury and Bobby's wondering is it just
skin or intestines it actually looks to
be pieces of intestine Bobby so when we
first saw him hiding behind the tree I
just thought he was having a snooze and
as we moved around I could actually I
just got that smell of stomach so the
chances of it getting infected are very
very high and especially since it's
dangling like that if he moves through
the bush I could get tangled on unstuff
as you've seen there I'm just gonna move
a little bit forward
shann big boy
okay they've him now as I said the what
happens to him I'm bad I'm not the one
who has to make those decisions but JK
is asking if he's euthanized will you be
euthanized if you pass there's a danger
towards the Safari vehicles and stuff
like that
again it's not it not my place to answer
those questions okay but I think a
careful decision will be made over the
books like this is just a fish
Bart of blood coming out now something
moved and you can on the back right side
it so I just suddenly saw a little gush
of blood coming out there we go
and as I said if you are sensitive this
is not for you we we're not going to be
here the whole afternoon I'm just
waiting to hear back from the
authorities and soon as I've heard back
from them I will be leaving I just need
to know whether they need GPS locations
and things like that
it doesn't look like he's gonna move
anyway it looks like he's been here for
quite a long time now of course seeing
stuff like this is difficult in Emma
who's asking does it ever get easier I
should hope not I mean to a degree we
are immune to certain things
what more immune than people who don't
deal with it on a daily basis but it's
never nice to see anything suffering
animal or human so if you get too used
to it I'd say there's probably something
wrong with you so he's just been moving
around this tree throughout the whole
day I can see from the tracks he's
flattening the area and and he just
can't seem to get comfortable now you
can just see it he's been there kicking
up the dirt spraying the dust on that
wound sorry I need to answer the phone
quickly so next if you need to link away
can you please do it I get crushed -
Taylor hello hello again everybody we
got our elephants I think it was
fantastic by the way it was really quite
nice I've been searching for a herd of
elephants for I cannot tell you how long
most of you know sorry I didn't get to
share it with all of you I'm trying to
think what we're gonna do now it was
very cute it was a tiny little baby but
maybe some of you were lucky enough to
get to see it on the dam can and I'm not
gonna go to the Birmingham mails cuz I
know they're going to be fast asleep so
we'll probably come back a bit later and
I suppose we'll just drive around and
see what we can find maybe do some
birding so that's going to be the plan
for now maybe we'll hit on over to
Chitra we'll have a little look bit
later mm-hmm
let's go this way because there's a nice
mud wallows down here
surely around here I don't I don't know
we're gonna just try to find some more
elephants because I'd like to spend a
bit of time with them as I haven't spent
much time with
at all just that nice ball that decided
to stay for like two seconds this
morning ever had a quick ride bath and
then continued chasing after that young
Colin calf that were there before him
speaking of elephants roadblock
right whereas a road that we're looking
for hopefully we'll be able to find some
elephants and then we can have lots and
lots and lots of chats about them but
seeing though we're just doing a DNC at
the moment Jason you've asked how long
does must last with elephants and it
depends again some it can last for up to
two weeks um it might last a week so it
just depends on their their age and sort
of social status perhaps if they're a
very big strong bullets in prime
condition it can last for a little bit
longer than others some opening around a
week or two
I've also laid the tracks wasn't
electric in fact it was flying a
footprint ski hyena mud wallows done oh
sorry everyone I'm eating ice it's very
hot just under 100 fahrenheit so we're
busy still formulating a plan I'm just
waiting for another phone call should be
hopefully won't be here longer than
another 10 or 15 minutes while we get
the right people on the way that's the
biggest danger with this aliens not now
while it's quite fresh still it's in a
day or two when it gets in if it gets
infected with with intestines and stuff
it probably will he could become very
aggressive and take it out on all sorts
of things including vehicles bush walks
lodges and housekeeping ladies while
they're collecting and stuff like that
so at the moment he is nice and relaxed
but he is a potential danger down the
road a little bit
Oh No Ludmila was asking is there any
chance that Eddie could have got better
and I was sort of humming an airing but
then he defecated and his done came out
runny and full of blood so you see there
VMP so it wasn't the normal blob nope
let you hear from an elephant and it's
yeah so it just sort of shot out and I
could see specks of blood in it which as
I said is not a good sign and it means
he's wounded quite badly somewhere in
the digestive tract so there's in fact
if I'm honest with everyone yeah there's
very very little chance of survival for
this elephant and said that wound
probably happened last night so
yesterday although it's very difficult
to tell especially with these edibles
because they keep throwing dust all over
the wounds
it's a shame big boy now unfortunately
this is one of those realities about
living out in the bush but sometimes it
isn't all strawberries and cream now if
we we take a positive from this elephant
dying this elephant is died will die
from a natural cause and a wound from
fighting with another elephant bull
coaster Islander is asking what animals
will eat it now that's the positive that
if this elephant does die it does
provide a huge amount of food and
nutrition back to the bush lie I've seen
lions hyenas I've even seen leopard feed
off dead elephant and but most it'll be
lions and hyenas and apart from that and
apart from the lions and hyenas the
beetles the the carrion beetles the
scarab beetles the dung beetles flies
maggots a whole host of other insects I
mean it's is his legacy will be putting
back to the earth in terms of nutrients
and and food for other animals
I say at the moment he's trying not to
move too much but he can't help himself
I'm sorry you guys I need you
okay so Nikki we still having tech
problems with other vehicles um I do you
need to be on the phone for quite a bit
okay it sounds like Taylor has moved out
of will fixed her gremlins or moved into
a good signal area so I'm afraid I'm
gonna have to disappear for a little bit
to try sort out everything about this
elephant and hopefully we'll be back a
little bit later with Hosanna well we'll
see how long our signal last fall as we
aren't hitting it to some other areas
now tarnishing these guys that I'm loved
and I can't stop and have a chat and I'm
sure they're going to go and look for
horse honor but I'm not gonna go and
look for sauna now because I know that
Brent would like to look for hot sauna
so we shall go down this way we're just
gonna drive up and down on some roads
with lots of mud wallows and hopefully
find the elephants because that's what
I'd like to do I think it's gonna be too
hot for the cats to be doing anything
right now I mean the weather was 36
degrees Celsius it's warm it doesn't
actually feel that hot hey it's warm but
it's not not too bad
nice with a breeze gentle breeze still
continuing from this morning so that's
quite nice and refreshing so we want to
keep on the go or stop in the shade I
don't want to be stopping in the in the
Sun that's all not on a day like today
there's actually not that many birds I
maybe we'll have a good chance of
watching some birds splish and splash
around in the water but not now as
everything is hiding away from us at the
moment which seems to be about normal
we're looking I'm looking for anything
that's moving in these bushes and maybe
should keep my eyes on the road at some
point - all that rain that we had even
though it was nice soaking rain and
we've had a couple of roads that don't
like the rain very much caused erosions
so some of the roads needs to be
regraded again and I'm pretty sure when
Drake sent us back accidents coming back
when he's going back Wednesday I think
I'm pretty sure in between drives you'll
be back at it again and his big tractor
perhaps dragging tires or first scraping
the roads
check in the trees anybody sitting in
the branches no that's well we'll try
our luck maybe we'll have to go into the
molarity perhaps catch some elephants
that side or if you go to Tristan who's
got something that flaps its wings
pretty quickly
I do indeed now it's bouncing around all
over this plant and making it a little
difficult to see but it is a butterfly I
was saying that there is noticeably more
butterflies flying around today and I'm
just trying to ID exactly which one it
looks like maybe a dusky copper that's
what it looks like I'm just waiting for
it to open his wings or now it's flying
again I was hoping and we're just to a
little open for me then we'd see it it
keeps going away and then landing back
on this plant so we're just gonna wait
for it there we go it's now landed once
again in the same spots and it's opening
every now and then and gives a little
bit of orange tinge so it does look like
a little dusky copper over here I know
there's lots of grass in your way I'll
try and get that rid of that have you
got a deer Craig lots of wind as well
which is not ideal so a lot of
butterflies already flying around that I
have seen this guy I've seen some of the
little spotted blues I saw citrus
Swallowtail monarch even some of the
crias are around as well so it should be
a good afternoon for butterflies
hopefully what's gonna happen is we can
hit a bit of a wind and the wind will
then settle down and it will cool off a
bit and then these butterflies should
stop from flying around it will make it
a lot easier there Craig it's not
actually even closer to you so but it is
bouncing around all over the place which
is making life ideal that's all for poor
Craig Craig's ending to bounce around on
different plants all over the place but
isn't it beautiful with those little
spots and stripes and markings and the
winner it opens its wings it's more
brown on top with a little orange
section so I'll just double-check
exactly which one it is but I'm pretty
sure it's one of the coppers I'll just
have to double-check
exactly which couple sorry Craig that's
my fault I've dropped a piece of grass
and fry pause Craig its face but they'll
be out because there will be a number of
plants and there are flowering and with
the bit of rain that we had in our and
little sunshine and gonna have perfect
conditions for butterflies to go and get
all the nectar
out of an pun out of these pants and be
able to actually feed on that now
apparently you can see its proboscis
going into the plants and actually
feeding off that nectar which is very
very cool it's not every day that you
can see that now in terms of the
difference between moths and butterflies
you can see how this insect keeps its
wings closed for the most part and it's
very very active now during the day a
moth is far more active during the night
and when it lands it will land with its
wings down and flattened against its
body or so if you look at these guys
they have club like antennae so very
thin antennae with a little sort of
swollen into it where's moths tend to
have a feather like antennae that gives
them a little bit of a difference
between the butterfly so if you're
wondering how they kind of work and what
the difference is between the two then
that is it
but very very cool excuse me so I was
just cooking there a little bit it seems
as there's a lot of insects out she's
just looking around a lot of buzzing
about and lots of flies and all kinds of
other things so hopefully we'll see lots
of different types of things now
sorry Nicks if you could just repeat the
first part of that question I heard it
turns into butterflies but I didn't get
the first part David what percentage of
cocoons turns into butterflies those are
difficult things to say I think it
depends on different areas I would
imagine that some areas there's a lot
more predation then there is in other
zone I mean if you look at out here
there's going to be huge amounts of
animals it'll predates on poor little
caterpillars that are going into a
chrysalis to start kind of hatching so I
actually wouldn't be sure as to what to
say to that I I know last year though we
had a fallen over tree with the Koreas
that went up at one point I think there
was about 12 chrysalis on me and after
about a week there was only one still
dangling so if you go on mats you'll
have you know a very very very small
percentage but it depends I think it
depends on the area that you're in the
amount of predators that are around how
well they conceal themselves when they
go into that state and they then start
to kind of going through metamorphosis
it's going to be interesting I honestly
have no idea though what the percentage
would be in
system like this I think we would have a
you know it would be something that
could have to kind of monitor you'd have
to get a sample size and then try and
work it out amongst them right let's
carry on Craig to see what else we can
find
Patrick you're asking if I have a
favorite butterfly I don't know if I
have a favorite individual butterfly but
I do have a favorite in terms of a
family of butterflies so my favorite
butterflies that we sell is actually two
one is the Shrek C's family so the
Traxxas family for me are absolutely
beautiful and there's one called the Fox
roxies which is a very very cool name
and then also the swallowtails so things
like the citrus solid tail are
absolutely beautiful vivid colors quite
large butterflies and there were these
little tail streamers that come down so
those two families are really my
favorites and the ones that I like to
see the most difficult to find around
here that in certain other parts of
South Africa you can see that maybe I
would be on that list but those are the
two kind of families in particularly
here in this part of the world I would
say probably the Fox you sure taxis in
the citrus Swallowtail
on my two favorites that we see
hopefully we'll be able to find either
one of those this afternoon would be
quite nice like I said did see a
Swallowtail fly passes just now and so
while I go looking for them and seeing
if we can find them
let's hand you back to Bryn - I think
his left that poor elephants and is
carrying on on his way and let's see
what he's gonna be up to so welcome back
guys I know a lot of you would prefer to
stay there and stuff like that but at
the moment I don't want to add any
pressure on that animal the sabi sands
are on route I will go back and take
them there a little bit later in the
drive so for the moment let's see if we
can find our little prince this is where
we left him this morning and I said it
was a sauna it's unlikely that he's
lying in the same spot during the day he
likes to cruise around and he is not
there so he was lying at the base of
that little bush there this morning so
he's not there there's no tracks of am
heading down towards that elephant which
is probably more most sensible for him
because I think that Eddie would take
most
and kindly to the presence of any
predators at this very moment but I'm
gonna just check some of the other bits
of shader on yeah you might have moved a
little bit during the day I'm just
saying if the other game drive vehicles
tracks hit off a little bit so what
we're doing is they're my eyes playing
tricks on me let's have a quick look
look wait I saw spots in this thicket
but I think I've got spots on the brain
okay well I try to figure out where the
Sun is gone oh no you're staying with me
it seems like the gremlins are art
enforced today
now the Birmingham boys are back on the
property and child of the universe is
asking what how far away from this
injured elephant they're actually quite
far
we're down towards south east of Zima
and the birmingham's are in the north
the northwest sort of afternoon Henry no
updates just yet battle-ax Road is zoned
due to injured elephant bull so please
take care of that err no sign of a
signer yet we're trying to follow up but
till the sabi sands has come to have a
look at the Eddy battle Arizona okay
we're just checking all the little spots
of shade where's a sign that I liked a
little loop on to the road see if his
tracks come out but in the meantime
let's go see where madam mccurdy is
heading to next
well brain she won't believe who we just
spotted it very briefly but that's big
Tusker that was chasing her around this
morning he's basically between mumble
road and drakensberg and she's I think
I'm hoping he's following a breeding
herd because that's a breeding herd I'd
like to try and find so we can't get to
the elephant of course because he is in
the middle of the thicket and you all
know I don't all froude for elephants
especially not a masked ball never so
we're gonna just drive around you but
I'm just checking carefully in the
thickets it's so easy with this long
grass and big trees to miss a fully
grown elephant even to miss 30 elephants
and I would think that he's trying to
find breeding herds especially if he
isn't masters and I could we're talking
about earlier he's basically just going
to be driven by his testosterone at the
minute they will be munching along the
way but he'll be marching and marching
constantly trying to pick up a scent on
a group of females are these brains
actually
let's go say hello to Breen t I'll tell
him that his friend is coming to mind in
perhaps that's what maybe that's what
that elephant is doing hi grant your
friend the elephant must bull is on his
way to you on his way to do you think
he's given him a hiding mmm his brain
brains on the radio let's watch my brain
operates the radio from so he's trying
to follow tracks I'm actually gonna turn
around cuz I don't want to squash any of
hassanis tracks maybe we'll go down
towards Chatsworth so this is the area
brain twos workings a brand might even
find that herd of elephants the nitrene
said perhaps that big fella has already
given another young bull were hiding and
we were talking about this the other day
in fact where we had that very well
rowdy young elephant bull and playing
with another elephant bull and if a big
Tusker like that came across that young
fella being cheeky he may meet the same
well not good on the same road and tusks
him that happens quite often in fact
very sad for that elephant though very
very sad but i don't think there's much
you can do if its intestines are hanging
out not great at all no for those of you
who haven't met Daryl the elephant who
is my favorite elephant he roams around
on the sabi sands he spends most of his
time down at earth lunch at sabi sabi
and he's that elephant with a bell shape
in his yeah all the snapchat symbols
some of you have said looks like the
little ghost and scenic you've asked if
this testosterone makes elephants a
little bit cheeky a most certainly it
does and Daryl's a prime example of it
whenever he comes up and causes havoc
he's normally in must but he it's like
he enjoys the vehicles and causing
trouble with him and what's required
funny because that was like one of
David's first elephant encounters
interesting and he had been working in
the bush at all then came straight from
the city and then Mitch Darrell with
Scott so yeah and he's not a small
elephant either so you say yes it does
seen a cute quad ride it's an it indeed
makes them cheek yeah so you just gotta
be wary of them and give them a bit of
room and and just well watch them
sometimes they're fine sometimes they
just carry on with their day I don't not
particularly like viewing eleven bulls
and that's just because I've had some
not-so-nice and counters within which
I've told you all about but job anyways
it seems as though Tristan might be
stomping around perhaps it's because
he's got ants in his pants hopefully we
won't have this minions in my pants
because otherwise I'll be very
uncomfortable but we basically have been
looking around and there's so much
insect life after the rain that we
decided we'll have a little look under a
fallen over log just to see what's
happening and there is just a myriad of
ants going absolutely crazy so they're
all over this tree and they're moving
around they've coming out and they're
kind of streaming up and down there's a
whole bunch on the ground as also I feel
nope of that that we moved it so we'll
put it back nicely just now but it's
amazing to see how many oh yeah there
must be hundreds of thousands events
going up and down utilizing this old
dead tree is a way to be safely housed
and to be able to hide away from various
predators that might be Archer you'll
find that's why things like even odd fox
sometimes will try and break towards
these kind of trees and dig underneath
and try and link it to all of this that
is moving on you can actually see that
some of them are busy carrying eggs out
of the actual area and moving them
around in fact I don't even sure these
are ants some of them some of them might
even be termites there's an interesting
one that's kind of going along which is
this individual over here and it's
moving very fast although it's gotten
hidden but it was a really large one and
it was in amongst them that was moving
quite quickly and what looks a little
termite black and what could be
happening is sometimes you'll have
termites in these kind of trees like
this and the ants actually raid them and
they try and kind of take the eggs and
actually even carry off some of the two
mites as well and so ferocious predators
they're amazing things to watch but it
also looks like some of them
trying to have a little look because
difficult to see but there's little eggs
that are actually being carried as well
by these ends so there's some of them
are picking up little egg lavas and
they're now moving them along deeper
into the actual dates of this tree to
try and just hide them our way a little
bit better so I'm not gonna actually
spend too long here because I obviously
we've disturbed their nest a little bit
so I want to put it back nicely but
before we do that what you will find is
also over here is that we've got a very
interesting situation there you've got a
carapace for a dung beetle by the looks
of things now what that could indicate
is two things either the dung beetle
when it was very very soft decided to
kind of lay its last egg in this area
and bury its little ball if it was one
of those that does bury balls or there's
a situation where they might have been a
scorpion living in this particular tree
and so as we have these kind of dead
trees you'll find lots of scorpions live
inside here particularly a scorpion
called pista canthus ESPA and they spend
a lot of time kind of moving around and
dead trees and they'll hunt you various
insects from then so what it might have
done is actually quartered fiddleford
and then this is just the exoskeleton
that is now left after the scorpion has
fed which is pretty crazy
very difficult to say how many ants are
in each colony as you can see here
counting this many ants is nearly
impossible one because they are moving
so fast to because there is just
literally so many that you'll be here
probably for the next ten weeks trying
to count all of these answer difficult
to say I would say that they must be
easily thousands within this particular
colony because it's not only here that
there's a lot of movement there's a
whole bunch of movement on the ground as
well so there's literally ants all over
the place here you can see where Craig
is sitting the ground is literally
crawling with ant species that are
moving around so there's far too many
for us to count in to know exact numbers
also the way that they go back and forth
to individually know which and you've
counted and which one you haven't would
make it very difficult you probably have
a situation where you have far too many
ants - that should recount now a Nichols
don't
it's incapacitated oh my goodness sorry
about that everybody
Tristan for the ants get him
perhaps they lose this video she doesn't
get ants in his pants
maybe they crawled on in there and he
had to stomp around I don't know what
just happened they and sorry driving
down she to cut line now looking still
looking for her in avail of them so I
know how long it's going to take me now
shall we play a game on how long will it
take Taylor to find a herd of elephants
I think it's going to be another three
game drive so this afternoon I think
about tomorrow afternoon or the
following morning I might put a herd of
elephants on screen we'll see we have to
start the counter again and oh I see
some Impala up ahead we can go and have
a look at them maybe they'll once stay
around and quickly check yeah fort in
Ghana I should probably ask the guards
if anybody's read okay so don't think
I've seen as I'm approaching the area
let me do that Sheldon Sheldon can you
copy me
I'm just chat to Sheldon quickly Dylan
Dylan potato maybe they're not even in
the East anymore oh I just can't hear
them also a possibility who's shouting
in yeah
oh there's what those weren't there the
fighting hornbills so cool listen to
them very chatty
they run why are you being long pants
it's a hot day there aren't quite warm -
they're very chatty in these - flying
around looking for beetles and all sorts
of other things that may be crossing the
road what is it doing
and the ones coming in to join
now they're done did you catch something
no no caterpillars I always enjoy
watching hornbills feast but now you can
see sadly not successful but we'll just
give the beak a good clean anyways very
cool now I can hear the babble is very
nice well let's go down to the little
pan because I think that's where all the
Empire and gathering perhaps you're
gonna see Wilbur the warthog that would
be nice surprise
Wilbur the warthogs pan has filled up so
much you won't even recognize it
he might have to be careful he might
have to wear a life jacket if he wants
to go in there now speaking of animals
popping into the road
Avon wishes you've just asked about
whether a leopard is ever popped onto
the road and while I've been driving
yeah I'd actually happens often a gajima
does that to you and then you normally
just see his tail disappearing and who
else has done that arkaroola has done
that so many times or there's so many
elephant tracks here but they're all
going this way I think this is the
breeding herd that was here oh my
goodness all the impala and the sabi
sand will stop here and they might get
to be a bit nervous for now but I reckon
they'll settle hi how's it going Apollo
where's Wilbur and this is really nice
actually listen to the sounds as well
this great audio of these Impala
all very nervous all very chatty at the
edge of the span now if you have no idea
who I'm talking about when I say Wilbur
Wilbur is a warthog he's my favorite
warthog he's got no hair on the end of
his talent he's an old boy he chased
Gwen out of her warthog burrow out of
the Burrow in the termite mound and then
took her free zone it was probably his
first which was quite funny but he's a
very relaxed warthog and he normally
lays in the corners of the pans and he
staggers he can drive right up to me
doesn't run away which is quite nice
because the typical sighting we get
every war Tigers as well their bottoms
with their tails in the air and by the
way all talking so much it's like it's
all the lands are separated from their
mothers and they sort of all doing their
own thing just chatting with one another
supposed to keep in contact to say
everything's okay
all a bit nervous down at the water's
edge though they don't drink for long
and if you've ever noticed that I mean
animal just doesn't keep its head down
and down and down though drink for a
couple of seconds and then put their
heads up and look around and that's
important because 10 Ghana was not far
from him could be a crocodile in the
water it could be a number of different
things but very nice to see so many
Impala we've been having some great
Impala sightings in fact we're very
lucky we better make the most of them of
course off you go to Kosta Tristan who
is having a look at some of the flora
I am indeed I haven't seen one of these
in ages and well I'm so excited that we
found one it's a small little bush that
we've got right in the middle of well
just close to the damn camera I didn't
actually know it was even here which is
very very exciting now what I apologize
first before we carry on about our
little criminal attack we had earlier
and 40 I don't know what happened they
went back to our plant we have the most
delicious smelling tree we have Archer
when you pick this and you squash it and
you smell it mmm smells like a lemony
month's kind of smell so it's known as
Lapierre Java Nica or fever tea and this
part is really really cool it's used for
a number of different things it's a
really good plant for things like smell
if you've got cuffs if you've got any
sort of
blockage in your sinuses you kind of
will use this and if unfortunately that
elephant did die it would have a
situation where you could put this in
your nose if you were going to that
caucus and all your smell is this lemony
mint smell rather than this horrible
kind of rotting meat smell so often used
to do this with kiss whenever we used to
go to a caucus you'd pick this and then
you just shove it up your nose now of
course you look absolutely weird when
you do it and I'll do it for you guys so
that you can see it looks really odd but
I promise you if you've ever smelt a
dead elephant and you would know that
you would do this it would be much much
better for you so basically you just do
something like that
now there we go do I look good jeggings
basically that's an all you smell is
this really fresh kind of minty lemon
smell as opposed to rotting meat it
really makes things much much better now
I'm probably sure that most of you can't
you see Craig is definitely laughing
behind other things that they use this
plant for quite interestingly enough is
it's used is a plant that they will rub
on people and they say that it keeps
crocodiles away from you so if you're
ever going into an area with this
crocodile infested water they reckon if
you rub this on yourself the oils from
this will repel crocodiles I'm not sure
that that's very very true it's an
interesting kind of thing the other
thing is also is if you have meat that
has been infected with anthrax they
reckon that this plant rubbed on that
meat will actually get rid of that
anthrax I'm Batesville about that one as
well I don't think I'd want to try and
eat anything that's infected by anthrax
after it's been rubbed with a plant but
you know these are the things that
sometimes people believe and so it's
quite an interesting plant for me it's
just the most amazing smell and you can
make a tea from a substitute from it you
kind of boil the water and you put it in
and then you add milk into it and it's
actually not too bad so it is actually
taste alright I have made tea from it
before it's not the best he'll ever have
it's like a green tea but it is pretty
good nonetheless and I didn't actually
know that there was one right yeah so if
anybody in camp knows what sinus issues
this is where we need to come to be able
to get it is a really cool smell now all
I can smell is
intense lemony and and it kind of feels
funny non it's the leaf is a bit
scratchy so make sure there is each a
little bit so I'm gonna have probably
canes me you have like this Wiggly nose
as we do the rest of this segment now I
was busy talking about just now when we
got so rudely interrupted by the
gremlins I was talking about and
swarming so the only time we will see
ants swarming is if there's a food item
so if let's say if you had home
you see ants and you drop maybe a sugar
solution so sugar and water you'll see
the ants will then swarm around that in
order to feed off it but other than
that's not really there also I suppose
if they in defense of their their nest
then your finance will kind of come in
and try and defend in a big grouping but
and then not really they just kind of go
in lines and they'll go and find food
and they distribute art but they don't
actually swarm anything unless it's
either food-related or in defense of the
igneous that they are close to so it's a
pretty interesting thing to see and
answer a phenomenal creatures are
absolutely love them there's actually a
thought that if they were the size of a
medium-sized dog that none of us would
even be surviving because of the sort of
prowess as pizzas they would have a
situation where they would probably just
take over completely I'm good we're
going to carry on we're going to try and
see what other little weird and
wonderful things we can find in the open
areas and see what there is and while we
do that let's change you back across to
brint
and find out whether he's had any more
luck with husana or if he's still with
the big grey pachyderms we back with the
injured daily sabi sands are about to
arrive so i'm just here to see what's
happening next a quick update you know a
herd of elephants have moved into the
area as well so he's actually surrounded
by other elephants now the problem is
apparently that big masked ball that we
saw this morning taylors bumped into him
already this evening and he was heading
in this direction so it could be a mute
object if that that must ball decides to
sort of finish the job I think he's the
culprit he perpetrated that injury I
can't see him at the moment we've got a
few down
towards in the area there now the big
problem is this is the last direction
that husana went so with injured
elephants and must bulls around we don't
really want to get out and track his
honor on foot and so I just I'm just
checking quickly here and sorry I'm just
make sure I can't see the big must ball
just yet you can see he's still
constantly throwing dirt dirt on the
wind
okay well I can see we're starting to
move now I know you can see there it's
the same Eddie okay I don't want to be
stuck here with the other elephants so
next I gotta get out of here so are we
gonna send you across we don't want to
be caught out in a bad position with
these Eddie's so I say you gotta be very
careful when there's injuries around
just moving out of the way giving them
lots of space okay so while we see
what's happening here next let's go
across to Tristan to see how his Bush
was going well Vince I think it's a good
idea for me to get yourself out of the
way of the ILI's and make sure that you
do not get yourself squashed on rusty I
rather like rusty and so I don't want to
see something happen
I'm just being all say you as well we
don't want to see you getting yourself
into danger and so hopefully that will
all play out now we're still just
ambling about having a look and I'm
trying to look closely at all the plants
because I'm sure we're gonna get some
cool insects after the rain that we had
over the last few days with the Sun
brilliant sunshine you've had since
yesterday we should have had quite a few
insects starting to at least lay eggs
hatch or be in the area and so we're
just kind of walking and trying to check
and to see what we've got in this
section and it's been lots of movements
but nothing really sitting still which
is what makes it difficult in the
afternoons when you're doing insect
looking
so Dale yes the scorpions in this area
all of them will glow under UV light so
they have a chemical within there within
the exoskeleton called hylene and then
hylene reacts under UV lights and you
get this glowing scorpion so I'll try
and do you I don't have a UV light with
me and we're not gonna be arts late
enough for it to be really dark to find
the scorpion and actually do it but I
will try and find one somewhere along
the line and one of the drives are in my
heart and we'll try get a UV light and
show you but this the answer to that is
all about scorpions here do now I
thought I saw some color I did there we
go so there's probably one of the more
colorful feathers that you get out here
it's a bit bedraggled and probably came
out during the course of the rain but
it's form what looks like a lilac
breasted roller feather and you've got
these beautiful beautiful blues purples
that come across this way and it fades
into a more sort of like coloration so I
would imagine this is from a lilac
restaurant it was a purple roller we
wouldn't get this brilliant electric
blue here and the European riders don't
get for this kind of color almost
purpley blue towards the edge of the
wing so from my lilac breasted roller
and like I say it probably came out
during the witch you can actually see
the tips of the feathers all kind of
bonded together and because this is not
on a bird this is what would have
happened if the bird was still wet and
then if it grooms it with its beak and
kind of goes with a beak a little bit
and just sort of runs their beak through
you can see the feather starts to
actually gain its shape again and starts
to look a lot more healthy and more
feather like so that's why they preen a
lot after rain is why you see them
fluffed out and why they try and then
run their beaks through their feathers
in order just to soften everything up
again and get them looking into good
conditions so that they can fly
effectively but this would have been
like I say during the rain unfortunately
and then put whatever have to grow
another one it does happen quite
regularly that they lose feathers from
now and maybe now then
good carry on not so interesting kind of
things happening I feel like there's a
lot of growth of grass that's what I'm
very tall but interestingly enough as
I'm walking around here it's really
actually not very thick so the grass is
quite sort of patchy in places you can
see lots of big gap between the grass so
while we've been driving around
at the moment and we've been moving
around we've got a situation where
there's kind of you think that there's a
really thick carpets of grass over the
last few weeks but it's actually a
little bit less than you think and once
we get some really dry weather this
should die down quite quickly and we'll
actually see that it's quite barren
store there's a lot of big gaps between
the grass sort of clumps and that's
gonna mean a tough winter still for a
lot of our animals even though the grass
looks healthier and longer than what
we've seen this thought isn't that the
cover that we used to have back in the
day right I just heard some of the just
heard some great go away birds along
quoting little bits I wonder if maybe
they're Wahlberg's Eagles are not around
talking about a lipid that killed the
cheetah today and in the Kruger Park I
gather is where you saw that because I
did see a post about it why would that
have happened so basically well how that
happens and it's something that is quite
common particularly in certain parts of
the Kruger down towards actually where
her community comes from crocodile
bridge it happens there every now and
then and basically what the situation is
is that generally cheetah are going to
be catching and hunting and killing
something like an Impala and they are
hunting in areas on the fringes of quite
dense area big thickets and they kind of
catch things in the open and what
happens is let's find them there and
they rush in and they grab these cheetah
and get them while they are still
feeding and they've so preoccupied with
the feeding process that they don't see
the liquid coming and then it would
being a much more physical stronger
animal grabs them and then kills them
and they have a situation where they
unfortunately then get you know dead and
then they drag that pin to the tree in
eaten so the leopard is a very
opportunistic animal it's something that
it will try its very best to try and
find food all the time and whether that
be an Impala or a cheetah is irrelevant
to them nutrients nutrients and they
will go after and they will actually
feed on them it's not like they're going
to just put up in the tree and leave it
they will actually eat cheater so it's a
not a common common thing but it does
happen quite a bit in the Krug I think
in the last few years I've seen maybe
seven or eight at incidents at least of
Leopard killing cheetah and hoisting up
into the tree and eating it so not a
very nice thing to witness and certainly
not what we want to see but that's
it's how things go and it's the way it's
gotten for many many years in the past
so well just have to you know hope that
the cheetah population wherever it may
be continues to grow it's been a good
couple years for cheats in the Kruger so
it should be alright now we'll carry on
we're going to see what else we can find
I think prince squatting myself out of
that sticky situation and so while we
carry on let's go back to him and find
out what happened sorry about that guys
we're still busy trying to sort out the
issue of this elephant the sabi sands I
just had a chat with their theory if you
if anything has to be done with an
elephant has to come with well
mpumalanga which is the province when it
has to be notified to the the parks
would sorry guys
standing by
it's accid fun day there now between
Battaglia and Yared South in that Cova
so Spaghetti Junction that side is fine
the specialist update could alarm called
sort of sounds like all arrayed north
Junction with central reg I'm following
up
okay so we've zoned that area and we're
not letting any other vehicles into that
area that much will arrive while we were
there looking at the injured animal the
injured animal immediately started
walking towards us that's what you saw
there we couldn't see the big masked
ball coming so we've just left that area
completely alone and we're gonna go
follow-up so while we were chatting they
were kudu alarm calling directly north
of where we were so around since Road
and I'm pretty sure that's a signer so
we're gonna go have a look in that area
now so it will do is we're gonna head
down there and switch off we're gonna
listen and see if we get any luck with
the little prince
so we were sitting down there June North
will be anywhere from yeah so let's just
turn the engine off and drift down the
road hope to get some of those alarm
calls so it's quite late in the
afternoon so probably nothing will be
done about that elephant at the moment
as you can see that that wind doesn't
seem to be hampering his movement and
whatnot too long or too much but the
problem is it's not now while the winds
fresh it's once the stiffness sets in
and especially because it's a gut wound
in a in five days or four days time when
it's incredibly infected and that
animals in a huge amount of pain will
become incredibly aggressive and that's
where that elephant might be a possible
problem so we'll wait to hear back from
mt PM which is the government body and
I'm pretty sure they'll be sending
someone out here tomorrow morning to
subtract follow-up I don't think that
elephant is going to move too far from
that area and but unfortunate we will
not be doing any elephant tracking on
foot while we are I mean but leopard
tracking on foot while we've got all of
that over there so let's hope asana is
deciding to be kind to us this afternoon
and stays close to the road so I don't
have to go walking in the meantime let's
go see where madam McKenna is heading
back to camp seems to be like a common
train these days I promised the I'm not
trying to sneak off of Safari Wendy's
been fine mechanically and then all of a
sudden doesn't bother once we started
the car we carried on driving she's
making a shuddering noise and I've
opened up the hood of the car and it's
very very very hot inside there well I
don't I don't know what it is because
the fan belts still going around and
round and open partner running across
the road I'm not really sure so I've got
oboz' number and I was a mechanic by the
way I hope he may be he's not yes
there's no such thing as a Sunday when
you work in the bush so well first we're
gonna get rid of that sneeze whoa that
gave me goosebumps thank you and we're
just slowly making our way back to camp
I seem to be losing power
so my foots quite far down on the
accelerator not really going anywhere
anymore so we're just gonna hope that we
make at home we're not too far away and
so I'll have a little look now only
driving along hopefully we'll be able to
hear what Daniel has just been talking
about and that is can another line this
well identify identify identify another
line from its rule now answer to that is
yep yes it's yes they can indeed and I
suppose we might not be able to hear the
difference all the time but some friends
of lions you can hear and well they've
got different pictures at which they
they rules so just like I don't sound
the same as David David doesn't sound
the same as me each lion rule will be
unique and of course lions can
understand one another we can't
understand them so they will indeed be
able to tell the difference and remember
that's how lines try and find one
another if a coalition say the
Birmingham boys have all split up and
one is looking for the other you might
do a big rule to try and locators his
fellow coalition members or the same
thing within gorilla pride for example
if any of the lionesses they get
separated they often start with contact
calls if they think they're close by but
if they're a little bit further away
they might end up doing a roar and then
obviously the rest will reply and then
that's how they'll find one another
which is quite cool I think and likes it
sometimes you can hear it especially
with the male lions and if you get to
hear them roar often enough you'll be
able to know be able to notice the
different types of roars like the one of
the four ways males punches two boys
that lived at sobby sobby for a little
bit they then moved on though they went
into Kruger and then when the trials -
the Mail's arrived and the one male with
very orange eyes had the deepest roar
I've ever heard mind
life it was so cool does the gratis rule
of any lion it was amazing he wasn't a
particularly big boy either than he to
listen what she lacked in size he made
up and in his raw it was really quite
cool in fact so so yeah that's quite
nice yeah I haven't heard a lion roar we
hear them obviously for a distance but I
haven't had a lion roar right next to my
car since I've been back in they say
that would be a lovely treat that really
would and shoe must be excuse me must be
all the grass now I'll chat as long as I
can we're gonna be pulling into the
workshop shortly so one last question
from Katia and that is if I had any a
close calls with any of the animals yeah
my most recent one was with an elephant
in fact an elephant Carlin on
treacherous chitra looking at this
breeding herd and then this cow sort of
came out and she didn't look very happy
was so far away in the next minute she
just ran and she pushed the whole tree
down to try and get to us ah reversed so
quickly David were you with me again for
them again again again again David was
on the car with me so yeah that wasn't
fun and I mean it wasn't a close close
call I moved away that if I think about
stayed put and I didn't start the car
and drive away I would have been a lot
of trouble she would have moved me and
hippos have had close calls with on foot
I have also had a close call with
Buffalo on foot before a buffalo that
was a lot of fun outside the tent and
then also with elephant balls in must
that I didn't necessarily know where
master I was trapped got trapped by
breeding her on it first to droid once
when I first started guiding that was
terrifying all right I'm going to send
you to Tristan news what would be
walking around here somewhere if I look
carefully enough I could see him I'm
going to very quickly open the hood of
my car and see what's going on with it
but off you go to Tristan
you
you
welcome back sorry about that folks I
was I'm on the phone again just with the
guys making sure that everyone stays
away from that area with the general
manager of Joomla
he just wanted an update so just giving
him a quick update so I'm back and
hopefully Tyler gets her tech 4x quickly
and so does Tristan now I'm hoping that
Osama is somewhere in this area I nearly
said quarantine you know that you know
that's a blast from the past area
because how many times we've had
quarantine here sure
at least 2530 was via Malone so I just
sort of and I haven't been on Juma for
quite a while so and almost said
quarantine be nice no it wouldn't
actually be very bad for her lipid
dynamics of quarantine arrived but this
is the area where we heard those could
alarm calling so just been sitting
quietly and listening and unfortunately
we haven't heard any more alarm call so
I'm gonna check down a little bit
further towards in the other edge south
north and the eddies are down in there
and we're gonna keep clear of that area
for now it is absolutely sweltering
today it's a good thing one of the most
important things when you're out in the
bush and it's very hard to make sure you
drink enough water
it's not uncommon that will drink two to
three liters of Awards of water in one
drive especially at this when it's this
temperature is 36 degrees Celsius and I
say I'm quite impressed with myself I
was on the phone to Jamie after drive
this morning and I said today is going
to be a stinker I think it's going to
get to 35 degrees and it was 36 so not
too far off now I'm also trying to use
find the kudu
this is another good spot let's actually
just get down into the shed let's have a
look around yeah now of course it's
beautiful and green at the moment but in
a few months it's going to be quite
brown and gray and it's our fire season
the scenic is asking about wildfires and
do we ever get them we do occasionally
and we also have controlled fires we do
control the burns in this area a lot of
people think fire is bad it's another
one of those massive misconceptions
because fire is good most of sub-saharan
Africa outside of the forest block which
is obviously the Congo Basin rainforest
from the rain forests in West Africa is
what you call a fire climax biome and
what that means there's a lot of species
particularly the grass needs the fire
and to climax and that means it will
destroy and burn all the moribund dead
grasses dead seeds and it helps enrich
the soil and so after fire with a little
bit of rain you get incredible growth
incredibly quickly and most of our trees
are here are fire resistant or fire
retardant so they don't actually get
damaged that much and even the small
animals like tortoises mice and rats and
and those type of things the vast
majority are able to get into the bottom
of the thickets of something like a
quarry which is fire retardant and
survive the the fire so fire is actually
a very good thing traditionally in
Africa and in this type of area those
wildfires would have been started by
lightning during the dry season all
right at the beginning of the wet season
and they could have burned many
thousands upon hundreds of thousands of
hectares these days because of people we
control them so most depending on the
type of soil type of grass most areas
are most effective if burnt once every
two to three years so you'll have
different areas that your cordon off and
burn every two to three years and what
that does more
and these Eddie's everywhere and what
that does is creates a very healthy
ecosystem with the right balance between
trees and bushes and grasses okay now he
seems to be heading up north sir I think
let's do that so there might be some
Eddie's heading towards bottles hook
down and we can sit there and listen and
we should still be close enough that if
we do hear alarm calls again we should
be able to dash into this area
well while we're going through here
Paula is wondering about species of Arab
ever gain trees this is one here the
tambuti tree is an evergreen tree and
you see if I rip the leaf like that it
will start bleeding a milky latex now
that milky latex is highly poisonous and
can burn one skin but timber teas are
evergreen we've got lots of evergreen
trees actually
the vast majority are not vast majority
of the deciduous but ever evergreen
trees we've got another one right here
in the African evany the jackal berry is
another evergreen tree and it's only one
or two occasions are evergreen and such
as the black thorn which was also here
most of your evergreen trees will grow
around these little riverbeds sorry
vampy the black thorn is all the way
behind you
gory bushes so yes we have a fair number
of evergreen trees I apologize that is
not a black thorn is it I apologize it's
just a very green decree status no
sickle Bush so a lot of our trees and
bushes are evergreen one of the most
important ones in terms of animals due
to its palatability is the ziziphus or
buffalo thorn
this is a very important evergreen tree
and during the winter months it's not so
important during the summer months but
during the winter months you'll actually
see a browse line where parler Bush back
in Jana and could move feed on it
extensively as well as elephants so that
is the buffalo phone and it's got the
most wonderful Afrikaans name it is a
blank blood vaca Becky boss dr. Becky
Boehm
yeah that's what I'm correct yes so it's
called a wait a bit which translates to
a waste of it bush or tree now the thing
is is because if you ever get stuck in
it you have to wait a bit to get out so
not only will it impale you
on a very sharp straight thorn it will
hook you with a very nasty hawkthorne on
the underneath now of course if you are
very popular at being eaten you need all
the defenses you can get now not only is
it popular amongst animals but it
actually goes very well in salads
especially when they're nice and fresh
and green like that now apologies at the
moment that I'm the only feed their tech
issues with both Tristan and Taylor
Taylor is asking me if I'm at a firm
Taylor and so
see I'm the only feed at the moment say
it could be a while
I can't so we're gonna try hit towards
Buffalo cuarto up see if the Le is gonna
go for a swim
read back Shrike
sitting nice and high perched eating as
many insects as possible before the long
flight home
well back T woods Europe red back tracks
that have been ringed in South Africa
have been recut in bird net in England
can you believe so they'll be taking
advantage especially after that little
bit of rain we had of eating as much as
many insects as possible before their
long flight back towards Europe are very
pretty bird
now certain birds will shed feathers
from time to time and that is called
molting and first lady is asking why on
earth would they do that
well those feathers become damaged will
affect their flight patterns and whatnot
so they're constantly getting new
feathers and that's why they take a lot
of effort and grooming and keeping those
feathers in pristine condition now it's
very important if you are something like
a red-backed Shrike who has to fly that
incredible distance all the way back to
Europe for the summer so they spend
European summers in summer and African
summers yeah so they just live in summer
permanently now we heard those cool
I'm calling quite a while ago so it's
not impossible that husana might have
even got this far so always a good spot
to check
this is still definitely one of my
favorite roads on juma in the alla road
north is we meander up the little river
system that comes out of buffers have
done
just wanna check yawn the soft sand no
no sign of a signer coming this way
now of course after the rain and there's
been a bit of an explosion in insects
but not so much in flowers James was
asking about baboons tail have they
started flowering after the rain no
James and they're very unlikely to there
are normally they normally flower with
the first rains not the last rains so
they're their flowering season is well
and truly over it's very unusual to find
any baboons tail flowering this late in
the in the in the season
okay unfortunately guys sir although we
are stable and here in present Conrad is
running around like an absolute man mad
trying to fix bushwalk and Wendy but to
do that he has to reboot our whole
system which means you're going to lose
us as well I will give you a little bit
of a warning before that happen but in
the next little while there's a policy
when you're going to have to go and
technically we will be back hopefully it
won't be to be hopefully we'll have
Taylor and Tristan back as well if it's
just me we will soldier on don't you
worry
welcome back unfortunately so far it's
just me bush walks trying I'm not sure
about Taylors is a mechanical problem
sir Oh paws on his way but for now
yeah stack with the wildebeest and me
now as I said it feels like a bit like
the old days again and for those have
you been watching for a long time both
of you on that River Valley when we only
used to do one vehicle Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday and we only
put two vehicles Arts Saturday Sunday is
that right for me two vehicles in the
afternoons I on the weekends so and the
week we also only used to do there were
only four of us we didn't have enough
stuff that was it can you believe that
three just over three years ago there
were four of us five of us it was Billy
it was Brian Andrew you mark me that was
it
and then Scott Nikki then James came the
enemy Jean Dre oh I can't even remember
her ass sure
so I'm not quite ready to give up on it
so I'm gonna do one last big loop this
area we found where the kudu were but
they were looking very relaxed now so
maybe in a sauna went off that way so
we're gonna do another loop Central Road
around towards quarry pan and then maybe
back down quarry pan Road and then if we
have no luck maybe we'll go visit the
billions
now on Twitter marvel the Beast now a
person composing posting our fabulous
selfie that about that cheetah that was
killed by a leopard near chalk one and
it sounds like the cheetah killed an
Impala the leopard obviously heard that
commotion Rushton killed the cheetah
hoisted the cheetah as well as eating
and wasting the Impala if I think I'm
correct and also next now I've
completely gone off on a tangent and
forgotten who was asking about that Amy
sorry Amy and Amy is wondering do the
cheats they ever come into sabi sands
yes they do
Amy there's actually quite a reasonable
cheetah population in the sabi sands
however where we are is not the best
cheetah country in the southeast and so
there are some more open areas on the
gabbro soils where the cheetah spend
more time Tristan was the last person to
see cheetah on Juba and he saw I think
it was a female in three sub-adults
three sub-adults in the beginning of
January somewhere around there if the
last person to see chicken gonca on on
Jima I've seen them on Chima
three or four times I've seen the same
two males the ones we used to see on
cheetah planes I've seen them on Zuma a
couple of times and then I've only ever
seen one female on Jima and that was
actually on foot so I wasn't here I was
tracking a leopard and Hampton - a
cheetah and she got too frightened he
battled off but yes they do you come
into the sabi sands strategy and I South
Africa is is the only country in the in
Africa where cheetah occurred where
their population is actually increasing
so even Kenya Tanzania the cheetah
populations there are decreasing and the
cheetah the cheetah in South Africa are
increasing the largest meta population
of cheetah in in Africa
now when I say meta population I mean
the population with the greatest China a
genetic genetic I don't think this such
word is Janet a genetic diversity and so
therefore the most viable population of
cheetah in Africa we're actually sitting
in it right now all driving through it
right now it is the greater Kruger so
they're there and there's incredible
work being done by ewt the endangered
wildlife trust at spreading cheetah to
as many reserves as possible now I think
I might have mentioned a while ago that
I was excited to come back to Juma but I
was a little bit disappointed because
there's lots of stuff going on in the
reserve with my pensive and my dad's in
charge of all of that and so the day I
had to come back was the day we released
the male cheetah from from the boma and
caught lions and did all sorts of stuff
and I was at work so I would have liked
have been part of that I've been part of
big cat can capture quite a few times
but it's always an exciting thing to be
part of and we actually ended up moving
them so my dad's neighbor ends the
Safari wines shop with suppliers wine to
a lot of the lodges here and he donated
his wine delivery vehicle and for that
day it wasn't delivering wine
it was delivering three lions from Kapaa
ma too late wait so these three
lionesses in the Burma but back to the
endangered wildlife trust and and and
and cheetah so they've got a really
incredible program with cheetah and wild
dog that are reintroducing them to a lot
of reserves where they haven't been for
a long time and there will actually
almost give you that she's there with
and a lot of things as long as you're
adhere to their their sort of approach
course and what happens is then if they
know the exact genetics of all the
different cheetah that are outside of
this meta population and then they're
able to fully move and control moving
males and females from different areas
to make sure that the cheetah have the
best chance of survival with the highest
genetic diversity so that they're doing
absolutely unbelievable job I must
having I take my hat off GWT and a good
friend of mine is actually well he's in
charge of the wild dog project for this
part of the world so when you see the
colors on any wild dog yeah my friend
grant is collecting that information
now speaking of cheese and a cheetah we
came to know and love you has
unfortunately probably disappeared his
Malaika laura was asking is there in any
word on Malaika
not that I've heard Laura unfortunately
not since her two boys were seen calling
for on the banks of their ala Laura Rock
River there hasn't been any word on her
just yet so I'm hoping that she's still
around but I mean she's such a
recognizable cheetah in the fact that
she hasn't been seen now for probably
over a month means that she's either I
think she either drowned overtaken by
crocodiles so for those of you don't
know what happened but like it was a
female cheetah that Jamie followed the
most to spend the most time with but we
all spend quite a lot of time within the
Mara I saw awesome incredible stuff with
Malacca and the Mara's had a huge amount
of rain recently and the cheetah was
seen trying to cross a flooded river and
the next day only to Mayor the two young
boys were seen and there was no sign of
Malacca now that was the last I heard I
haven't I have kept a sort of not a
close eye but a sort of a distant eye on
what's been going on out there and so
far I haven't heard anything about
Malaika yet she was probably the most
famous cheetah in the world and at the
moment I think the five boys are
catching up they're so very very sad but
again like that elephant early on drive
today
these things happen up in the bush it's
it's it's I shouldn't say it again but I
like the way it sounds it's not
strawberries and cream really bad sad
harsh things happen Archer and that's
nature and it's in human nature to want
to try interfere and try sort of change
the outcome of what's going on but when
human beings do that it actually makes
things worse at the end of the day so
it's better to just let nature take its
course
it is a it is a difficult one but that
is the right decision Eloise is asking
about the two boys are they okay
Eloise I'm not sure I'm not a hundred
percent I will find out how's that I'll
speak to Scott and Jamie you are up
there and see if they've heard no it's
good so what do you think Sam great pan
or Purple's
let's go Chloe pan I think that's the
most likely spot for him to pop out okay
well I'm sure you are all sick and tired
of hearing the sound of my voice in my
continuous waffling so let's go listen
to some waffle from Tristan well quite
right and waffling is something that
both of us care the talent for and can
do it quite regularly so back to camp
and try and sort out some stuff with the
pack in with the camera and regarded
alright and so hopefully that's the last
of the gremlins then they are gone and
that they leave us alone for the race
but it is a beautiful beautiful evening
we've had a bit of cloud cover come in
and is the most magnificent sky off to
the south but these blue blue blue hues
with this kind of wispy cloud that's
there and then to a sort of western side
we've got a eastern side we've got these
massive storm build apps that are
happening so you can see these big
clouds then it was beautiful color in
them as the Sun is starting to set so
they're starting to get pinks and
oranges and it is a wonderful time to be
out walking at this time of the day it's
one of my favorite times of the book in
the bush
it has everything is just kind of
sickening down the wind is settled
completely but I will tell you one thing
that it is gotten incredibly humid which
might be an indication now we're gonna
see a little bit of rainfall at some
point tonight I wouldn't be surprised at
all it feels very close and muggy and
sticky but still a beautiful day to be
out and about
so Bobby you asking if there's a time or
season when ticks hibernate so no there
can be ticks throughout the year you
can't have a situation where you'll get
ticks both now well in winter all the
way through into the summer months but
obviously there's a much higher
percentage in the summer and you pick up
a lot more in the summer and the reason
for that is because that's when they
start to breed and so they have a lot
more little babies at that time the
grass is also much longer and so there's
a lot more space for ticks to inhabit
areas and when you walk you then pick up
a lot more so there's a higher
percentage during the summer months when
they're breeding but you can find them
still in winter it's not as much but
there definitely is still ticks in the
winter months so it's something you've
got to be aware of and you've always got
to kind of pay attention but it's
drastically reduced number during the
winter then there is during the summer
as the grass dies down a little bit now
all the process and it just through the
question parts you can just repeat trust
in the fact that I have walked around
enough in the bush to know that I'll be
ok and to trust that I've spent enough
time with some very experienced people
who have shown me a lot and taught me a
lot and walking with guys like Herbie
and Rick's you learn and you kind of get
to a situation where you become a lot
more in tune with what's going on and so
I find one walk that's for the 99% of
the time you feel fairly safe and
particularly open the chances of us
coming across something that's going to
be very very dangerous is very slim
you'll see it long before you get
yourself into too much trouble and so
it's not so bad i lashley love walking
so I always feel fairly comfortable on
foot it's just that you've got to be a
lot more aware of what's going on and
take nothing for granted so even though
it is a comfortable feeling because you
do it a lot it's not to mean that it's
complacent so you can't have a situation
where you get complacent and you sit
around and you don't pay attention to
what's going on because then you're
going to get yourself into a bit of
trouble but definitely
uncomfortable feeling walking good well
we're gonna try and find some stuff it's
getting quite dingy now so hopefully the
insects gonna just start cycling a
little bit find some of them or maybe
see if we can find some flowers off the
rain but while we do that so believe
Taylor mccurdy is also solve her gremlin
issues and there's also out and about
and ready to entertain all of you we're
back up and running and stinky what had
happened was iPod actually serviced
Wendy today which recalled you for her
so he gave the engine a good clean and a
good spray so what it was it was just a
plug that it actually got wet and
because of that it was causing the car
to misfire and we were losing power and
all these things but we pull we windows
opened it all up took basically a
compressor sprayed it down dried it out
and no we good now something I want to
show you is the skyline and all of a
sudden as soon as you pull down a camp
that smell of petrol core was strong in
the air maybe they're not sure what
petrol court is it's every earthy smell
sort of like a mold and fungus and wet
soil that you get before you have rain
these clouds have come out of nowhere
the smoke and this morning earlier today
I did mention I was like all these wispy
cirrus clouds which typically mean that
we're gonna get rain in a couple of days
time but perhaps we've been having
cirrus clouds and in the last few days
maybe with all the rain and we have had
and I just didn't notice them but it
looks like I think we're gonna have
another storm on our hands maybe not now
I definitely think a little bit late or
perhaps tomorrow morning just
interesting on a Petrus call smells
around them and then another good news
as taxane has managed to a relocates
on the Birmingham's so that's where
we're going to be heading in a minute or
so we've just got her of course set
gate darling so let's go I'm so happy
there was nothing really wrong with we
knew because she's been driving so
beautifully lately and so well
let's sum it so Pitt state because I was
confused I thought to myself my goodness
why is this car doing this so hot all
sorts of things that smell is heat a
great RV it's a beautiful smell mmm it's
really really nice okay well we haven't
got far to go till we get to the
Birmingham's hopefully by the time we
get to their heads they're not laying on
the long grass it'll be good to Tristan
he's found himself another flattered by
I was saying now that we it's starting
to settle down a little bit it's getting
a little cooler so things are starting
to get to that point where it's gonna
get dark and so a lot of the insects
will start finding a place to sit
particularly the butterflies and in
particular their careers they love
sitting on a grass talk like this and
this looks like a dusky area it just
difficult because not open its wings
just yet but I just want to double check
but it's got that white bar towards the
end of the wing tips which the dusky
areas do get and so I think it's one of
those but isn't it amazing how we've had
very few butterflies over the last
little bit and all of a sudden today
we've kind of had them coming out and a
lot more around it's been a kind of a
little mini explosion of butterflies
which is exciting because I know Brent
loves butterflies and well I really
enjoy watching them as well in a number
of you do too so really in peasant just
to kind of find them and and spend some
time with them now this one's being far
more cooperative then our butterfly
earlier and I must correct myself
because I said that it could have been
one of the coppers but it was actually a
hairtail butterfly so it was just when
we kind of got back I got to see a
picture of it from a screen shot and and
a number of you also coming to run it so
thank you for that and it's you know
difficult with these guys when you kind
of standing and trying to look at a very
small screen because generally we try to
stand quite far from the butterflies
because otherwise we spook them quite
quickly sir particularly this guy I'm
standing relatively far away allowing it
just to sit very nicely and so that prey
can get a nice shot of it which is
working quite well perfect that it's
sitting on top of the longest piece of
grass that we've got in our immediate
vicinity so that's making life a lot
better which is very very cool
so Paula butterflies in it say they
there will be one or two migratory
species that we get so something like a
brown brained white they will migrate
African vagrants do a little bit of a
migration but there's nothing in the
scale that we see the Monarchs in in
North America that's a far bigger scale
than any of ours but the brown vein
whites do do into a migration I remember
when I was a little kid I used to spend
time in an area not too far from here on
the Drakensberg mountains and that area
we used to see a situation where you
know we'd have these brown vain whites
coming over this hill and down and we
just get this cloud of white coming
through it was really very very pretty
and just to stand there was just this
flurry of butterflies coming possible
almost like being in snow so really cool
to see and you know since when I was a
kid was seeing those I haven't seen them
in since then which is a bit strange and
it's a bit of worrying when you start to
see English insect migrations getting
less and less and probably due to the
increase of farming Goods well hopefully
there'll be more little things lying in
wait for us while we move around so
while we do that let's send you back
across to brains you still driving I
wonder if he's gonna get any luck with
the little chief I'm trying desperately
now what makes it quite difficult at the
moment because of the injured alien that
must pull in this area and to walk and
safe where he is he's far away so
normally but I would have skedaddled
three little well being in the same area
as a sonic it's important for my my
general well-being that I don't
occasionally you come across those
situations on foot while you're in the
bush that's that when you're not yeah so
you know those situations and get out of
their safety so to put yourself in that
situation when you know there's a
potential for your risk do you
the cheap the little chief
oh no sorry about that everybody my
goodness the gremlins have been terrible
hopefully tomorrow morning will be a
different story and we'll have all
smiles right I'm looking for Jackson he
should be here somewhere
he said that they had to move too far
and he's thrown the eastern side of the
road oh there he is now holds another
car Barrow - fabulous
now let's try and is it Texas at all
Bree this here let's try and figure out
where those lines are well everyone's
looking at us now just know it's the
most bizarre thing I've ever experienced
in my entire life I have to tell you
this quickly before we get there driving
into a scientist leopards and lions and
people stop looking at the animals to
look at us it's the most bizarre thing
ever
so he's try and find a gap I'd imagine
though that these cats are probably
tucked away I was saying to David I
would they wouldn't have moved too far I
think it was just when the Sun that sort
of moved towards the west
I think shining down on them because
they were covered by trees during the
morning all my goodness is a tight
squeeze it's just checkout see one let's
quickly have a look and see where we can
find the others there's another one okay
we might have to just take this little
gap David it's not gonna be great and
you even got the based end of him either
well a little bit I'm going to relax now
I'm going to get the news as you can see
the horizontal position but there's the
lion there's one of them and the other
two also scattered around the sort of
dwarfed silver cluster leaves and as
well as some of the bush willow trees so
they haven't moved far they've probably
moved a whole of I don't know maybe 150
meters that's it that's all
hmm no well obviously talking this
morning about the dynamics that are
going on between the vaca males and the
okay sorry and the Birmingham's and
Peter Viper you've just asked a question
why didn't the fourth Birmingham I think
it's informal that's missing why didn't
he come up and help chase away the Avoca
males well we don't actually know if
they had an altercation or not I mean I
don't necessarily think that they knew
that the vocal males were here perhaps
only once they arrived and they picked
up on their scent but we know what the
Birmingham is alike only when they come
back they're very vocal lines they start
calling from far away so perhaps they
started their rules as they were passing
through their old territory
maybe those youngsters heard it and then
well got on the move and obviously as
that sound was coming closer and closer
and in their direction
I reckon they would have got out of
there and the reason why that other line
I suppose is not here is it seems to say
he's quite comfortable with the moan
again breakaway pride but Tristan knows
quite about more about it so maybe he
can let you in on on that side of the
story and I think he said to me today it
wasn't for more that's down there so if
he's happy and he's found another pride
maybe he's just gonna stay a bit further
away and three big male lines versus
three sort of youngsters it's not I
don't think it's much of a challenge
like I say these boys are fit and
healthy they're in the prime of their
life they're not old and they're much
larger than those of our males and just
their bellowing roars all three of them
at the same time I think would be enough
to chase them away we're talking about
it today we're talking about how the
variants have definitely got an
advantage because it's there to if it's
there lad they know this area
exceptionally well these other fellas
are new they don't really know what to
expect what's around the next corner so
you know what it's like whenever you
have a sports game on home ground you've
got the advantage and the mattress here
the match was on at a birmingham's turf
so they've they've gone no one has seen
them now I think that they've moved into
mine unity I think they've gone back to
a spot that they're probably more
comfortable in and maybe that's where
they're just going to wait around
and spend most of their time until
they're up for the challenge until they
are big and strong enough to come on
through and try and take on the
Birmingham know these lines have also
traveled a fair distance in the day
remember that Birmingham has arrived in
I think winter of 2015 and and Avon
wishes you just honest where did they
where did they get their name from so
this kind of all ties in so these cats
have come from very far away from the
timber variety and there is a property
and supervisors remember these are all
old farms essentially and lots of the
times people name their farms and that
farm that the Birmingham pride is from
was called Birmingham so that's where
they got their name and they left the
pride they dispersed and then they came
on down here and well they all they kept
their name so there's a huge distance to
get here to I'm just seeing where
everybody's moving to perhaps we okay
maybe we'll do that H what we'll do now
is I'll try and get another gap here Tex
and has moved on up and around so there
must be another boy over there and I
think we should be able to get a bit of
view so while we reposition off we go
back to Tristan who's still looking at
the ends
well good luck repositioning Taylor I
hope that you find yourself a perfect
place in order to get a good view of the
Birmingham boys and so what we are doing
is we're sitting with a bunch of
harvester ants and I'm absolutely loving
watching them because they found
themselves a whole bunch of grass seeds
that they are busily carrying back and
forth into the nest and then they
carrying some onto the edges and it's
just a complete kind of busy array of
little cross seeds being carried all
over the place it's quite funny to see
because the ants are so small but he
cross seeds are kind of three times the
size of them and they're kind of
carrying them all over the place
absolutely fascinating to watch them
going about their business and how much
strength they have in order to be able
to bring it to the actual entrance to
the nest lots and lots of things going
on and amazing just watching the process
as they go about it and the way that
they kind of move
things about and it's always easy to
find these guys because of the amount of
debris that you find around the edges of
the nests itself there's a massive
amounts of little grass bits that are
all over the place and so they drag them
in and then they feed off them and then
they it will basically take the husks
outs and so this is all the husk area
over here you can see look how many
little grass seeds they've brought out I
mean that's all husks of grass seeds
that they've already fed on and then
dropped on the edges of their nest so
there's a really nice large one and
they've been taking advantage of the
flurry of grass seeds that have come out
over the course of this little bit of
rain that we've had in the last month so
really amazing to kind of see how they
do it it's incredible watching them and
his tireless work and never stopped him
so he saw the ants earlier moving about
and thousands of them up and down the
log and these guys are just as cool
because they are just constantly working
like this and imagine how much if it has
taken to take this many seeds out of
this area and to move them all over the
place like this it's pretty incredible
so David you'll find heavy rain can
effects and sin
particularly at times excuse me I'm
trying to talk to you go away birds
they've been very loud about this but
you're finding times of heavy rain and
we get flooding and stuff like that and
so are very perceptive so they often
pick it up long before we even know
about it and before the rain falls and
they'll then start to move and you see
them carrying their eggs and they
actually move into areas that are
slightly higher so maybe something like
a termite mound or even sometimes in
towards trees and they'll use trees as a
nesting point while it floods and then
once the they kind of flooding subsides
then they back down into the ground
itself so answer a really good indicator
for rain coming our way as soon as you
start to see ants moving and going away
from a nest carrying eggs and often
towards higher ground you know that
we're gonna have a situation where we're
gonna get a bit more rain coming our way
right now our ants are still busy
feeding and moving things around and so
we'll probably need them to do that as
the Sun starts to sit in the meantime
let's go back across to Bentley Smith
who's still driving about and I think
he's still hoping to bump into hasana
well I've decided to give up on this
honor for now just the fact is I'm sure
he's close by there but he's in that
same block as the elephants and as I was
saying I don't particularly feel like
walking amongst and amongst that whole
situation so my brother told me that bad
hooker Murray this morning heading east
towards western boundary and no one
really checked up there this morning so
I think we're gonna go have a shot
straight up for the ones cut line and
then check that new road Mendoza Road to
see if there we can find any sign of him
in that area so he was seen heading east
from nob full and open which is only
about 100 meters away from our boundary
so might be worth going to have a check
in that area
temperature is actually really Pleasant
at the moment it's just dropped a little
bit off that really hot period it is a
magic time of the evening
oh it's time for some language lessons
for Eloise we would like know it just
shop mean in South African slang
apparently I used it earlier I don't
even remember
can we used in quite a few different
circumstances it's SH double or triple
quadruple depending on how long you hold
the show for so it's generally
exclamation of surprise or shock so you
could say the Australians were caught
ball tampering and you could go sure so
those of you follow cricket learn and
use those Tralee ins have just been
caught being very naughty boys cheating
if the cricket so when I found out that
they were cheating into quickly throw
into the shop so and that's one way you
could use it I'm not sure I used it
earlier but yes that is that is it sort
of an exponent X exclamation of surprise
shop
not to be confused with shop shop shop
shop shop shop
was I'm gonna try get up towards the
western areas before we lose the light
and while we do that I'm hoping the tail
is going to have some luck and those
lions will start roaring early tonight
to make sure the Avars keep heading to
the north
well glad that's all settled down now
we're getting nervous
we had a very excited lion at one point
it was quite awkward to be honest now he
this male ever it may be laying upside
down like this was them yawning and
rolling around and I'm hoping that that
was the first of many and that the next
step is to actually set up and show
himself I can't see if I've been one of
the other males was sitting out for like
two seconds but there wasn't really a
gap to get in there but I think he's
gone down now I think he's gone
completely flat which is a pity we'll
see there's another vehicle moving so
I'm just gonna watch to see if there is
any more movement with these lines now
where they'd go and drink oh there we go
oh there's one hello moving in from the
back
oh you Limpy lu9 exactly is a bit lumpy
Jesus tin you'll see that couple of
scratches on the back right leg have you
been fighting obviously we couldn't see
much of them this morning let me go up
and go around the bend
wait Joe hates watch your hands no why
did you do that that was unnecessary I
don't know who that was it got up but he
doesn't have a couple of scratches on
his back legs that didn't look
particularly fresh to me they actually
looked like they'd scarred and gone
black already hopefully this other boy
is going to walk into frame not to you I
can see him sitting up so that's good
news I think he may walk straight in
this direction that might be near now I
don't know who we were looking at
goodness I it's been a long time since
I've seen the faces of a booming and so
you might have to help me I know that
informal has a scar under his right eye
where he had the attack of the my ASIS
remember one of the uncommon lionesses
swatted at him and then unfortunately
them flies got in there and laid their
eggs inside the wound and and then
basically it was a type of my Asus where
the the larvae of those fliers actually
feeds on on flesh and then ate a big
hole in his face but it healed up quite
nice it was quite a cool thing to see in
the wild unfortunate for him for more
but we did all did learn a lot from that
experience yeah here he comes and that's
the easiest way and he's got quite a
sort of beaten up face as well and then
Nana has got an equal sign and his nose
I think she knows the one that's got the
half moon taken out of his yeah as well
as well as them he has got a big cut on
his lip
well from where we was in a bit of an
argument and you can see part of his lip
is missing come on
here kitty kitty kitty come to us please
we've been waiting or patient
everybody's now left
here he comes yeah yeah I'm so happy and
then in sook who's just got the most
golden eyes is the most beautiful mane
here we go this is Nana but we've got a
beautiful equal sign on the right-hand
side of his nose hi gorgeous
that's a very pretty lion they do you
look at about a few scratches on them
but like I said it doesn't look fresh so
I don't know if they've maybe been in a
couple of arguments perhaps with even
the females down little bit further
south from here remember these boys have
been roaming around down on sobby sobby
and they've been moving around up and
Monda Losey Mala Mala so yeah crazy know
as we sit some hope that these lines are
going to set up and raw and I think they
may I don't think that they've finished
you know announcing their presence that
they've returned and I mean do you
you've just asked that question
basically about their rule how how far
away can another lion hear it's wrong
well we as humans can hear a lion rule
from about eight kilometers away and
that's what our very def is in
comparison to a lion it's hard to say I
reckon it'll be a couple of kilometers
more than that because I can't tell you
how many times you've actually seen
Lions the fast asleep like they were not
and then sitting up is sort of pricked
out listening quiet quiet and you can
hear a sound was even a bird tweeting
you know be one of those quiet nights
the next minute those Lions that you
were watching that were fast asleep
break out in a roll and that's when you
know that um that something is they've
obviously heard something they must have
heard other lions roaring in the
distance so I can't say exactly how far
away I mean you'd be able to do a test
if you had one private lines that was
sitting 14 kilometres away and you'll
meet us with another private lines and
the one fella said all my lines are
roaring and the other guy said all my
own lions have actually just popped
their heads up they listening to
something you know then you could be
exact about a distance but we know eight
kilometers as a human and I think it's a
cut probably a few more kilometers than
that we're just this is quite cool and
pretty amazing so like I said the
birmingham's are known to do that
they're known to start roaring from
quite a distance away I mean I'd be
sitting up and I'd hear faint roars far
far far far south from my bedroom and
and in the DRC it's quite difficult to
normally yeah and the sounds the sort of
can be distorted slightly because of
obviously all the concrete walls around
and you hear it gets closer and closer
doesn't stop every ten minutes or or or
or at all at your windows are vibrating
you think they're gonna fall out of the
framing and I've had that a couple of
times pretty cool when they come right
past can walk down past the cars so and
then you carry on hearing that until it
completely disappears so they make a lot
of noise and especially now that they've
smelt that the vocal mails are here
whether or not they they saw the mulatto
there was an interaction we don't know
we can't say for sure until we see the
Avoca males if they were all battered up
and got scratches well then we know
there was an altercation and they
probably won't come back for some time
but off you go to Tristan the light is
fading but the bugs are still out and
about they are indeed now this is a type
of beetle that we see very regularly and
I still can't find a positive ID on it
I've tried to find many different
examples of this beetle and I've come
close but never found the exact one that
we're looking at and we find them like I
said quite regularly on trees certain
bushes and often on the car itself as
well and it's a small kind of black
beetle but when you get a bit of light
until it gets this coppery Sheen to it
and it's very very round and small the
plankton and small legs it's almost a
little kind of ladybug like in structure
but it's not one of those and I can't
seem to find the exact beetle I've tried
numerous times because we see them quite
often you see them a lot on some of the
plants particularly this is Vania as we
see them on there and we must see them a
little bit on the wattles on the flowers
so I don't really know which beetle it
is but they are pretty cool little
things now I'll try and put my finger
roughly in the area of contacts you see
where it is oh there it is so I mean to
put my finger there and just give you an
idea of how large it is also try and put
the lights a little bit better for Craig
but is that a right we've got my finger
there so that's my index finger that
you've got just in terms of a relative
size between the beetle and me and they
are very common in this area good well
we are gonna start making our way home
there's a big storm coming there's
lightning
so starting to get a bit dark our chair
for walking around and so while we do
that so it's send you back across to
brains who is busy bumbling about
well we're now on the opposite side of
the property to where we've been and you
can see there's the storm Tristan's
talking about I don't think it's going
to get to us there somehow it looks like
it's gonna go further down to the south
but we are right yet we're looking for a
hooker Maury now so this is the area
where you might have crossed that knob
for not open areas just or a little bit
to the right of that termite mound
through there so that's where he's going
to come from and so we're just having a
quick look through here as it gets dark
you might start getting on the move
start getting on the hunt or getting on
the st. mark
ah now since we've been reminiscing you
know about the old days then were
becoming when wheeze but sweet peas
asking about the coalition that came
before the Birmingham boys they were
called vomiting birds and you had hairy
very hairy belly my timber and ginger
met umber there used to be I think four
or five of them but since I when I
arrived there were only two of them mmm
they got chased by the Birmingham they
ended up down south and London Losey and
central sabi sands for a bit I think
they must have moved on to the next
plane now but so it was the matte umber
male lion coalition and they were really
quite old
so unlike the Birmingham's when the
Birmingham's came in the Mateen burs
were sort of right down towards the end
of their their reign at the top weather
is that these of workers have arrived
while the Birmingham's are still in
prime condition well it was what it was
really nice to see them this morning
they were looking spectacular hungry but
spectacular
what was that disappearing there
now of course their increments were bomb
shelled by the vocals of unites ago and
the little cab has I think been seen
Olivia I was asking about that I think
it has been seen I'm not a hundred
percent sure but so far they've seen
dribs and drabs of the Inca homers to
the west all contact calling trying to
find each other which I mean we've got
to remember when the birmingham's first
arrived that's what happened frequently
as well they would chase the in comas
now at bombshell in groups the
Birmingham's even killed he was two
adults in coma lionesses and sub-adults
female that they killed that that the
Sahara female right near Tristan's room
when he was working at sebum Billy and
the Inka Homer female was killed in
torture that second rock and we actually
got special permission to go into
torture did you come with me them was
Andrew Andrew came with me we've got
special permission to go into tortured
to actually go film that carcass
of course there were five Birmingham's
in the beginning one male died from
injuries received from a buffalo horn in
the lung looked like he had a punctured
lung quite quiet yeah in the West well
it seems like Justin's having a lots of
fun with flatter buys this afternoon
let's go see what he's found now we are
indeed so we've managed to find another
one Craig somehow managed to spot this
guy hidden in the plants because it is
really very well camouflaged it's got
this kind of similar Sheen to its that
the leaves do in South African vagrant
that is just sitting it's actually quite
a white creamy colored butterfly but
with my lights on and the greens around
it it's almost reflecting that green
color and blending in a lot better but
you can see that nice big eye there's
antennae and a very cool view of a
butterfly now because it's getting quite
dark and I'm using my lights just to try
and highlights it's a little bit for you
you can see that the butterflies are far
more relaxed then they were earlier in
the day we were struggling hyperactive
they were flying they were moving all
over the place
whereas now we're sitting I don't even
know Craig's probably maybe 20 cent not
even 15 centimeters from that butterfly
and it's just sitting dead still as it
tries to now camouflage for the night
and you'll find that these guys do this
they find a plant and they get into a
good position where they're able to then
spend the evening and relax but isn't
that beautiful
like it's a very pretty butterfly very
common here we see them regularly flying
across the road all over the place and
you can see there's beautiful veins and
the wings and big wing structure with an
upturned head very very cool to see so
well spotted Craig that's very good job
it is a very pretty little butterfly and
it's quite big actually I'll try and
give you a size reference so that you
can all see without disturbing it but if
I put my hand there hopefully it's not
going to fly away they don't give you an
idea of just how kind of big it is in
comparison to my hand so one of the
larger butterflies that we see in this
particular section much larger sorry I'm
trying to find a way to get a bit of
light on
much larger than any of the others that
we have seen this afternoon so far good
it is getting very dark now like I say
I'm trying to use a light highlight that
butterfly so while we kind of get hit
off home and avoid the rain and head
back to camp
let's send you across to Taylor with the
Birmingham boys and hopefully they're
going to give an almighty roar this
evening something because all three of
them jolted up as if they were zapped by
some electricity I can't get anything
but they were treated up sort of waste
from women on they're looking up north
well near no stuff there's a line but if
they have picked up the scent of the
Avoca males they are going to be on high
alert to any other lines that are moving
through the area
no big yawn Oh a trio of yawns very nice
who's that nothing football in the
middle well that very swollen face makes
you can't tell the difference between
them anymore
isn't that Junior that looks like an
fool hey what do you think Bobby you
don't have to help me everybody but you
can but you're a bitter identifying the
animals and I am like I said I've not
been here for a very long time and have
forgotten you use cats and what they
look like no hashtags fine either
definitely Nanna closest to us perhaps
and suku at the back no mine looks like
he's got a chip on its ear I also think
it's some superglue thinks it's in C Q
doesn't mean so cool say back a terrible
South Africa
but again these boys look so different
they will definitely got a few more
scars on their face since I last saw
them which is of course normal
considered in considering say that
they've been roaming around out of their
home turf yeah that's in suku those eyes
don't lie golden eyes and then I think
it's informal maybe its tenure that's
not here it's quite interesting but
we'll wait for confirmation from all of
you
lion i dean experts i don't want to mess
it up so it couldn't have been anything
too serious because he smiles i put
their heads back down very quickly and i
think they're gonna wake up soon it's
hoped that they just keep moving further
south and not north or east now
something that I've never seen of course
is different coalition's of lions
joining up with one another except to
single lines and Paulo you've launched
us that have I ever seen something like
that I haven't but we can pass it on to
Brent and Tristan who have also been
guiding from exceptionally long time and
worked in a variety of different areas
the only time I've ever seen it was when
two older male lions on their own each
on their own join up and Freddie and
solo which were both lions that sort of
came from Krug and pops into the sabi
sand the southwestern corner around
there so so those are the only two but
they sort of came together as retirement
they weren't actively going arts
marketing defending territories and
mating with females so just sort of
trying to stay alive and to keep out of
the way of the younger upstarts because
of course they would love to beat down
on some old old male lions probably be
good for the ego not so good for the
older boys and they worried they were
old males so that's the only other time
I've seen it but I've always know I
haven't seen before it does occasionally
happen though I've gained brain Ted in
my society where a single male lion in
Kenya trying to join a coalition but it
didn't work they denied him I know she
had a big scrap with him he was lucky to
get away with the scratches that he had
and it's quite interesting and panache
I'm sure it depends on the circumstances
for things like that can indeed happen
like I said I'm not surprised by
anything that happens in the bush
anymore not surprised if it's
crazy how things can sort of happen here
there's a big roll now big stretches
these boys obviously chomped down on a
buffalo this morning must have been a
small one that they caught cuz they
barely seemed to have subsided
substantially some we last saw them and
Elizabeth you've just asked of these
cats will ever eat other cats I've never
seen lines doing it before they're not
typically cannibalistic so they don't
necessarily eat other lines I suppose
that a pure desperation of they're
starving they might eat any put a fair
catch one and what I have seen though is
a documentary and I can't remember what
it was called we're a very old male lion
he said sorry I've told this story to
you before actually goes out and catches
a sleeping hyena and then eats the hyena
which he was actually just purely
desperate he was starving today and then
a few days later he came across a
buffalo that was stuck in the mud and he
desperately tried to kill it but he was
just so weak that he couldn't even tear
through the hide of that buffalo so his
days had come and gone it was quite sad
and quite ironic that the two of them
died together in the same mud water prey
and predator it was quite hectic I was
what an old documentary I don't think it
was eternal enemies I don't know what it
was but long it was from a long long
long time ago so I've never seen
anything like that but again when
desperation comes around these animals
are not going to say no just because the
book says that I don't do it and so I
say you can't actually ever be surprised
about what these animals get up to well
they've gone slightly more flat again
hopefully not for too long
hopefully they're going to wake up and
maybe give us a roll but off you go
across your brain to see if he's had any
luck with finding hasana
it's being almost apps whether there's
been no likes beside it's been very
quiet no tracks and the only animal
we've seen down in the South West has
been a single die cat true story but it
is at that time of the day when stuff is
about to start happening that's still a
little bit too light to whip up the
spotlight there's still enough ambient
light around that I can see
now Taylor was answering a question from
Paula about male lions joining up with
other male line coalition's it's a very
narrow window when that that happens you
can have two males and two males that
will join together but that isn't that
sort of three to five year probably it's
there probably no longer than a year and
a half or two years where where those
lines will be able to join in to a
coalition after that and after those
coalition's are established there's very
little chance another male can actually
join I've actually never heard of any
now the strangest terms I suppose you
could you could always say it was a
different coalition I had joining a
coalition and it's only ever been
recorded once and that was in the Mara
was the notch boys so there was a with
it four or five not children I can't
remember I think it was five four four
notches and what happened is that
strange enough the Musketeers scar
hunter more Ronnie or Seco moved in and
chased notched and there was only one
notch big male much left and he used to
lord over the marsh pride and and the
Mara River pride in that area around the
massara Marsh and so the Musketeers came
along and he's he split but he left with
it was five it was five he left with his
five young boys so that's never been
recorded and they formed another
coalition and it enabled knotch senior
two to survive a lot longer and and and
and take over another pride even after
he was a he was a decision he was senior
a senior age was able to survive a
little bit longer and Mesa made for a
bit longer with other females and as far
as I'm aware that's the only case of
that being recorded I'm not saying it's
never happened in the history of
violence before but that's the only case
where it's actually been recorded by
people I'm sure lots of stuff that we
would think was completely out of this
world
happened it just hasn't been anyone
there to record it
now since we are on a male lion
coalitions probably the most famous male
lion coalition to have graced the sabi
sands was the mahal males and Randy have
you seen all of all of them I did I saw
them when there were six of them
most people think they were five but
they used to be six mapa [ __ ]
and I saw them first and they're about
three and a half years old I was at
singita and I just had dinner and I was
walking back to my room and being a new
staff member I was living in the in the
Ranger trainee camp which was called
rooibos and all the tents were named
after teas very strange don't know why
you would do that but and it was about
hundred meters from the car garages off
in the bush and as I was walking there
with my torch I suddenly encountered six
male lions in my way to my bed so I had
to go back and get a vehicle to drive
back to my tent that night and then I
spent a lot of time with him over the
years
so I actually spent most of my time with
Sangeeta in the crew gap against the
lebombo mountains with the mountain
projects now the big pride of lions but
then when I was at lund Alosi it was
sort of the height of the more potholes
reign over the central sabi sands I've
seen all five of them take down a
buffalo together it seen them take down
a giraffe as well so yes I have seen all
all all of those bow lions and for those
of you don't know what
maha means and why they were called them
up oho so to the north of us yeah and
actually it eventually ended up yet
there was a security company that was
formed by the local community themselves
called them a poor horse and they got
quite a reputation for being very brutal
particularly with people who offended in
the rural communities they would just
take them out and they were very
aggressive
used to use some tactics that were not
very nice in terms of dealing with
criminals in their communities so that's
where the mapa whole have got their name
from now for those of you I'm going to
tell you a story that you will think was
straight out of a horror film about the
more powerful males
now mr. t was one of the more powerful
males he had a bit of a mohawk hence his
nickname we that was what they called
him up here in the north we actually
called him something else different at
Bundle AZ the trackers called them sat
on Satan and the reason they called him
Satan was because of this particular day
so what happened was is they were Ottawa
pride one of the Ottawa pride females
had been pulled across by some of the
other more potholes and one of them was
mating with her and mr. t ran in killed
her mated with her corpse while she was
dead and then proceeded to eat almost
every inch of it so the guys up here in
the North used to call her mr. t but all
of us down south
although all of us all of us who worked
with our trackers and stuff who saw that
our trackers immediately said that lion
is Satan Satan so strangely enough there
were very aggressive male lions with
with that with other lines they killed
quite a lot of females and a lot of
other males however we'd used to walk
them on foot they were not very scary at
all I don't think I ever got charged by
I'm a pothole once and I've probably
walked them well over 50 60 times on
foot maybe even more than that and I
never got charged by them or poorer ones
I got charged by it's a lot of females I
got charged by I have you got charged by
the shores males were there before them
Abajo
but anyway yes it was quite strange they
were pretty chilled on foot and they
didn't really give you too much ribs
they'd rather run away
I'm gonna see if we can find and you
know what I haven't seen since I've been
back there's a bush baby that's what I
want to see tonight or an hour in the
meantime let's go see how Taylor's lions
are doing look what we've got up in the
sky it's a moon that is slowly starting
to disappear because of the cloud cover
and I've also spotted the odd flash of
lightning in the distance and again
something has drawn the attention of the
Lions in the north maybe it is maybe
it's the Avoca males perhaps they're
calling in the fire distance
and who knows if these Birmingham's will
go charging on afterwards so I believe
that you'll think that the lion in the
middle is tenure awesome I'd trust you
on this one if he rolls over and he
shows his mangy belly then we will of
course well can confirm it well that's
how I normally identify them because
women have the most swollen faces and to
me they look quite similar especially
after such a long stint away and Angela
well done for being the first run in
fact to get all three of the IDS correct
that's fantastic news it really is come
on boys give us a big old roll I mean
that's what we're going to be after this
evening like I said to you it's been a
long time since I've had lions roaring
right next to my car and I don't know if
Maurice the elephant is actually had a
decent buy and roaring sighting he's
actually changed his outfit David
because this has become a ninja elephant
now amazing he got dressed and ready and
hoped that the Lions would rule for him
he's a karate kid see he's not as grand
as scoff that's too hot to wear scoff so
he's tied at around his head do you
think he can dream is behave being a
lion sighting confident karate in front
of male lions no I was supposed to think
about this but I got distracted and make
magic dragon lizard love the name by the
way that's great very creative so what
is the what is my most entertaining
funniest thing
i've ever seen a lion dude oh I'm sorry
Nikki I know you told me to think about
it only and then I forgot what is the
funniest thing I've seen a lion do I
don't even know where to begin my
favorite part is when they climb up into
trees the youngsters and then fall out
of them that's always quite entertaining
Oh watching a young line try and climb a
tree and go all the way up and go this
is easy watching them coming down that's
a stereo cool all the lines and we've
got more experience obviously I'm better
at doing it but the youngsters are I
really not well equipped it's farming
just didn't feel they've learned where
they need to put their feet Oh back in
the Eastern Cape down the southeast
coast of South Africa I also told the
story before but I'll never forget it
it was the pride of lions and the most
beautiful male line remember I showed
you those pictures of Mon Doral and in
the beautiful black man Kalahari line
and there was a huge puddle on the road
basically along the fence line they were
walking and there was thick scrub on the
other side of the road and this puddle
had completely covered the road and was
quite deep probably more than ankle deep
hmm
anyway it's the pride of lions and the
Cubs will walk through it some of them
leapt over it and this big male lion got
to the water's edge stopped put his paw
in and sort of took it out and shook it
kind of like what a cat does and then
walk to turn around and he must have
done a big 3 400 meter loop to get
around it he was not putting his feet in
order so looking at a big strong male
lion and seeing him being put off by a
puddle of water was particularly funny -
and the other thing that was quite funny
was lion defecating next to one of the
vehicles and on that vehicle trying to
leave the sighting and driving through
the dung and then getting slightly stuck
and tire spinning and the dung goings
onto the side of another car and their
guests indirectly but quite a Darius the
other vehicle was not impressed so so
I've seen a couple of funny things I'm
pretty sure I could think of some more
fire she just put my head down and and
thought about it but yes the cats are
entertaining
very quiet are tonight hmm
goodness tenure you might be the first
one to get up with all those yawns he's
starting to groom himself well obviously
these lines have got big beautiful means
and something that I do a lot is my hair
sheds all the time I'm often referred to
as either a German Shepherd or a
Labrador the rate at which I lose here
and first eight years ask to you the
male lions lose their means as they get
older I haven't really noticed that I
haven't noticed any hair loss you know
any bald spots forming on the male line
so I don't think that that really does
happen um but maybe I'm wrong again we
can ask Brent and Tristan but I don't
well Justin's not driving it which
doesn't come back to camp as a staff now
and we don't want to be walking around
but I don't think that that happens well
not to an extent rather than noticed and
I've seen some very old male lions
before it's very interested in whatever
is in the north could be a Prada lioness
maybe it's an Akuma pod that are coming
back maybe their contact calling for one
another
because from my understanding it seems
as though that then come on goomer
product quite split up at the moment
I mean they've all been seen together
and that's probably because the Evo cos
were around and caused a bit of a stir
and scattered oh seven minutes and 15
seconds for these Lions to rule for us
come on boys just one we just need one
to start and then the rest should start
chiming in and at the moment the most
promising one looks like it's going to
be 10 you know if they do raw I'm
telling you right now I'll get goose
bumps because the whole vehicle start
vibrating the sound is just amazing and
it just sends a couple of chills down
your spine there's a pretty cool thing
especially in such close proximity now
I've completely forgot who's just asked
this question sorry Nicky topical hey
ever to the Lions of a skier
anybody when they're raw yeah so um I
wonder I don't know anybody in Kampen if
see anybody in final control get nervous
when the Lions roar a bit when they raw
when they're right outside camp like I
said and that the windows start to
vibrate that's an intimidating song hmm
I think the first time you ever hear a
lion roar it's probably a bit on the
intimidating side but again the
adrenaline is rushing through you it's a
it's sort of you feel confused you don't
quite know what your body is feeling
it's a it's a it's a hard thing to
describe you have to just experience it
for yourself so so I think initially
especially anybody that comes from the
city and has never been out into the
African wilderness before then yes
definitely and I reckon the Impala must
panicky every now and then too or the
Buffalo when they hear that sounds going
on that means they're probably going to
be up and on the move I'd be a bit
nervous if I was a prey species I'll
check at night and in dark I was like
the fiery Nick night jaws have also just
started calling too right we're gonna
sit on tight and hold our breaths well
maybe we shouldn't hold their breaths
for that long and in hope but of course
these lines are going to rule let's go
and see what range is going to pull out
of his hat next I'm checking some of my
favorite bush baby hangouts I haven't
seen a bush baby since I've been back
out I've seen them in an English house
but much out and about almost always a
good chance just around the old bush
price right now I know a lot of you are
probably wondering about the fate of
that poor elephant who's got some of his
intestines hanging out and so it's been
reported to the parks board in Palmer
longer parks they will be coming through
in the morning to assess that animal and
it will be up to them what decision is
made I'm not going to lie to you because
I'm not that type of person I think most
likely
the most likely decision that will be
happening with that animal is it will be
euthanized
now just because of the high density of
people in in this area and safari lodges
and bush walk and tracking and all that
type of stuff it depends a very very
serious threat to anyone while on safari
or specifically when you're on foot now
the thing is he's fine now it's a fresh
wind he saw but you could see he was
completely relaxed around the vehicle
and so the the problem will come in in
about a week or so maybe even shorter
with this very hot weather where that
wound gets infected and it's almost
certainly going to get infected because
the intestine is punctured and you could
see blood and his his his his dang was
really runny so you could see that
already so the infection would Satan and
the fever first year that would cause
the animal a huge amount of pen secondly
a bow makes that animal extremely
dangerous now if this had been in an
area in the far northern Kruger
somewhere where the tourists don't go
and a section water had found it he
probably would have left it but but
because because it is in an area where
we operate constantly all the time it
does make sense and as I said I don't
want to lie to you that elephant is not
going to be fine and it is very very sad
and I feel very sorry and it's never
easy to see that type of stuff but if we
think about it logically it's it's
probably it's it's safer for everyone
and a lot more comfortable for the
elephant if he's what was that if he is
euthanized and because dying from
septicemia it's a little stained bulky I
thought it was the little kitty cat it I
want to put the light on a little
stained bulky if he dies from septicemia
or even pulled apart by hyenas in in a
in a in a it'll probably be two weeks or
so it's going to be a far far worse
death from so I think probably the the
as I say I can't be sure it's not my
decision to make but I think logically
that is the decision that is going to be
made when the parks gets here tomorrow
and I think that's best for all parties
involved the elephant and all of us you
have - oh who live and work our chair on
a daily basis